the Swedish Chef is back everybody today
we're going to cook but not just any
lasagna did mean lasagna a Ugandan
chuckles everybody that's right a new
series 500 parts coming right stop
zooming I can see you hit - basically I
was gonna cook lasagna and I thought why
don't we turn it into a meat so we're
gonna try and make you got on the
knuckles so let's do this let's freakin
do this guy's
so let's do the okay step 1 wash your
hands
gallant soldier 1 we're gonna make the
mince set 1 you chuck
now a lot of people don't seem to know
how to chop an onion based on what I did
last episode everyone because the layers
thank you - man which is a y and then
you do it like that so then you be like
that
mm-hmm this is how you cut onion okay no
big pieces disgusting by the way I don't
cry
Vikings real Swedish people don't cry
now it's time to cook it yeah now if we
didn't use butter to cook our meals not
some stupid oil ignore everything now
you're a queen Sweden call a caster dude
here's the thing why can't they design
like one of these for this called
cutting board that like you can flip up
the edges right so they can be poor the
stupid deep village so basically right
now we're making like the bowl enhance
some of you guys for the commenting that
I'm using soy me like I'm some sort of
soy boy that's not it at all I don't
understand
add the tomato thing
it's not the goal I make the mean spicy
we need some time now my fetch makes it
nice and good we're basically just
making Bolognese get some nice shots
Porto Ramsey always have nice shots that
looks okay right
hello next up we're gonna use not soy
milk to make the sauce some really good
songs aren't you are you lucky to have
some amazing Shepard melt the
butter and then you add the flour I
think and a lot of men one liter really
the thing about me is that it boils when
you're not looking
[Music]
because looking back I ain't very good
okay I forgot you need to add one of
these see that it's boiling and I was
looking I was looking mom I swear now I
forgot to mention you wanna taste it I
see you go right make sure done done no
one asked for closure right Nick all
right now for the fun part the lasagna
made there you've gotta be making let's
go everybody over there wait so making
lasagna it's kind of like building Lego
start up I'm making a base lasagna but
also you see that thickness you get
you're getting the thickness this is
what you might want real thing so you
pour a quarter of a across as I'm doing
right now that was a little more perfect
I was perfect that's always yeah same
same mean different sauce yeah what the
new thing for that quarter I think what
am i doing okay that's it that's it that
looks beautiful just make sure it's
evenly across you know
just like that just like that another
layer bazinga
oh look at that pretty smart
ooh that's satisfying it's almost like
Tetris okay
Oh same thing same meme different songs
evenly across my god it's very good
you're doing such a great job yeah
honestly it looks real
what do you mean okay last but not least
the last piece you know I'm hungry
[Applause]
[Music]
I think I might have to use it tomato
friend sure do this face like this like
this like fun wait are you doing just a
face to the whole thing
okay let me start a little bit
you go in the pot at the body now he
eats strong yes if you're like a 40 year
old mom and you want your kids eat your
lasagna just add the memes do you know
the way he's beautiful little smile
which will definitely be there after I
cook him now
let's pop this bad boy in the oven for a
couple cup
he's gonna go off to Uganda everybody
all right we've got 15 minutes left and
yeah it still looks pretty incredible
and it looks edible too damn you're
supposed to make it wait actually make
it wait that's right let's get it do you
know the way in five minutes you gotta
you gotta let it cool down
thank you for reviving me like that mean
I hope this will serve you as a final
okay it's beautiful but what does it
taste like now since I didn't put cheese
on top
you don't get that BP but you know I
gotta you gotta knuckles oh don't worry
about the consistency if you don't get
it Wow that looks great maybe I had a
little bit too much Sun but you know
sometimes in life you gotta you gotta
sauce it okay let's see how it tastes
like
what it's really good but it tastes just
like that one you can just heat in the
oven all right let's see what the print
the Queen says it's good everybody it's
good if you guys want to make it itself
post with hashtag lasagne knuckles
[Music]